let's meet here loving how how are you
see you how's everything going today are
you celebrating already oh yeah we've
been drinking since we got in the car
well is this gonna be like last year at
the Oscars where they asked really
ridiculous question no no we're taking
it very seriously this year so we have a
breathalyzer on the carpet lips together
and blow
sure what's your favourite drink so who
wants to go first
all right ready it's a point oh four
three you're halfway to the legal
driving limit so we've been breathalyze
in having fun just to make sure they're
having an appropriate amount of I'll
prove it to you
all right let's prove the test I'll do a
urine test everyone I'm gonna get to
zero breathe until it clicks you got
this
Oh click I heard it perfect point zero
zero zero
all right straight I'm on the net
straight arrow you got this you're
natural
yeah perfect point zero zero zero you
weren't lying not a liar drum drop yeah
caught it have you been having fun
already
we got a little bit we had to drams a
very nice whiskey in the car on the way
over
yeah we have a whiskey Advent as Jesus
warrants yeah that's exactly right
good point zero zero nine yeah yeah I'm
not trying to be all color but see this
is type of blowing is not like in
reminiscing a scientic ative no she's
able to just remember I'm cool too I'm a
whiskey drinker yeah and I saw some
Jameson coming out they're like why do
you think I made a beeline over here I
let that Jameson can be yours but we
have a game plan all right all right I
get it
let it out real nice you know you he's
familiar with the breathalyzer ready
good we got it let's see if your what do
you guess it is zero clapping it's right
he's actually right hang on I could
smell it
I opened this I know you're smelling my
breath you're smelling my breath um can
you guys please get resumes are you
looking to maybe grab a drink before you
head in there I love a little drink yeah
what have we offered you some James what
Jameson that's me Jason and some bad
guys J Jonelle this is basically an
alcohol commercial you know I like a bus
Monika's a BuzzFeed buddy don't stop
never stops website here's some tequila
are sweaty dangerous but they won't
they're all dangerous spirit you don't
have to drink the whole thing they're
all the work of the devil those drinks
give me give me a wholesome bear Matthew
does he want so much jameson for inside
doesn't once almost